alors qu'il ya quelques jours aux états
unis se dérouler le procès le plus
important de sa vie face à son ex amber
heard johnny depp était lui tranquille
ou au royaume uni avec des anglais
déchaîné
des anglais à qui il a offert quelques
notes de guitare sur scène
et
c'est justement pendant son voyage en
angleterre que le verdict de son procès
est tombé l'actrice a été reconnu
coupable et condamné à versé 15 millions
de dollars de dommages et intérêts à
l'acteur ont fêté ça l'acteur de pirates
des caraïbes s'est rendu à birmingham
dans un petit resto indien pour inviter
20 pote à lui on ne sait pas trop ce
qu'ils ont bouffé mais tout ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'il a refait la soirée des
restaurateurs avec une note de 60 mille
balles une addition aussi salée c'est
toujours le risque à prendre lorsqu'on
veut relancer tout le monde c'est pour
moi j'avais tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
60 millions voire franchement ils
étaient une vingtaine ils ont privatisé
le resto est ce qui explique que
l'addition est si élevé c'est qu'ils ont
un menu spécial ils ont fait énormément
de vin de caupenne le champagne plus
plusieurs milliers d'euros de pourboire
donc 60 kg savez 3000 euros 20 47 cammas
est énorme c'est pourquoi il a dû avoir
des bouteilles et autres étant que où
les vaincus ou 7000 euros thank you la
mairie à macky sall
et le détail de la note d'un chien alors
donc allé à toi
t'as rien ce mec là franchement oui mais
comme ils ont privatisé le lieu est que
ce soir là il y avait 400 couverts pour
privatiser ils ont payé 25 mille livres
de privatisation du lien c'est
quelquefois on sait pas à quoi des
livres de quoi alors par exemple à sait
combien 25000
voilà ce que c'est moi pas de 150
militants cinquante mille livres sont
cinquante huit mille euros cinquante
mille livres 58 mille euros par action
de 3 voilà donc 25 mille livres la
moitié pour privatiser le lieu
[Musique]
tu peux pas parler en euros se plaît
j'ai pas tout en euros mais a converti
dans ta tête tu nous lis
la bouteille de champagne le champagne
7100 euros au niveau est haut niveau
[Applaudissements]
en seconde et en
direct et à 1200 euros la bouteille et
exit les combien ça va vite après ils en
mangent pas j'aimerais le détail exact
ils ont pris des côtes mardi les sel
poivre c'est vrai ils ont pris les
cocktails très cher qui valait 200 à
chaque cocktail de 100 à 500 livres cela
nous fait
venir te fait confiance c'est sûr
et après celle çi ils ont pris des chick
chick assez le menu ce mois j'en ferais
tu m'en bats les couilles j'ai pas te
mentir
j'ai pas de raconter une histoire
évidemment je monte il a fait 60 mille
euros de manger des chicanes chic la
meba sénat et qui marche qu'il veut les
tarifs jeff beck le musicien
clairement qu avec beck 6-3
en gros l otan et qui a déjà excuse moi
n'aura fait une version aussi la leur ne
pas s'en sortir on dirait qu'ils ont
émis 27 % d'écart c'est 15 et n importe
quoi on sait combien passant euros- avec
85 des bruce sterling euro savait pas
127 euros par don de tromper
complètement s'effectue rectifie mais un
fossé 5 14%
depuis qu'il a 16 stades les plus
faibles que l'on un euro dont les rôles
tu nous fais chier c'est bon
les gars moi j'en peux plus rendez
compte il a mis 60 mille euros est ce
que vous comprenez parce que oui on vous
comprend castanet c'est déjà fait alors
j mais j'ai une édition très salée une
fois à las vegas sur le tournage de la
spéciale céline dion la courbe et ya
laissé sa décision
à
la bouche la spéciale c'est l'union
ces unions et donc j'ai voulu inviter
toute l'équipe et il y avait hier il y
avait notamment le regretté charles
aznavour et line renaud et ils ont
choisi des vins la carte devenir le très
bon vin et et ça m'a fait très mal au
sein de ladite l'échéance est un ordre
de grandeur alors c'était
en dollars ca devrait pas et qu en euros
ils ont pris du cheval blanc voilà
cheval blanc d'henri iv et c'était
c'était 18000 euros la bouteille
alors assènera des charges comme terre
comme c'est un truc très chic il n'y
avait pas les prix bah oui mais bon
ça va il a fait la spéciale s'est dit
durera donc
l'addition finale ça fait trente six
mille 40 contre 36 une carte ville
dollars à cause des bouteilles de vin
non attends il y avait
presque 18 une photo ce prêtre anti
émeute ont une histoire l'a pas l'air tk
fait bien c'était beaucoup de chemin a
été écrit si baugé a dû 1000 $ et
comment tu as payé sur 4 440 milles
ouais towers dans ces eaux-là très cher
charente miner est donc traitée avec la
tarte a mis 40 minutes à l'épaule
caresse la chaîne c'est parce qu'un
simple allez pas l'époque ça marche et
oui oui
voilà carte black us est en enfer on
était à moins d'en faire en métal sa
série en
métal mais tu es salaam et c'est quoi
une carte ans a
battu la paire de jeans
comme s'arrêter avec saisie des arnaques
avec ces idées moi j'ai vu venir la
moselle la moselle tous les trois jours
une visa electron
le pas mais non il fallait bien cela car
tu sais même pas énormément il ya mieux
que blake maintenant et qu'elle manie
qu'a toute blanche comment il sait lui
alors je ne sais pas moi qui l'ait je
t'ai vu sur un ami elle est toute
blanche en fait y'a pas de nom ya et il
y avait aussi la tête
je les ai vus sur la mission je les hais
cette carte là je vous dis que c'est
vrai c'est elle est sans limite hormis
nylon les retraits et pas de retrait en
ligne j'ai passé un mois j'ai passé non
sans préalable effectivement c'est des
ultra riches qui ont certainement à oui
c'est pas à nous ni dimon est rien c'est
de nuit noire et blanche y'a rien dessus
même pas le nom y'a que le site et la
paire est à noter que si tu l'appelles
ils sont quatre dans mon ans la brune
dont quatre dans le bail à cyril non non
non
[Applaudissements]
lino
est la maman de six
[Rires]
sinon c'est très très très rare non
c'est fou je savais pas ça non